this is in quotes while these analyzes
provide clues as to what motivates or
triggers rough sexual behavior several
questions remain enhancered jealousy may
be one motivated for men but rough sex
was reportedly desired and initiated by
both sexes so what the motivators are
for both sexes are particularly for
women remains unexplored
what are your thoughts on that Catherine
um
my thoughts on
sounds familiar
um but I think they're so you in terms
of the sort of at Explorer the what's
driving women to initiate rough sex or
to be interested in it I think there
could be a couple different things one
of them is actually what you were
alluding to before this issue about
the idea that you're that a guy may want
you so badly be so passionately in love
with you that he is not as careful as he
might otherwise be and you know there's
a long history of women finding that at
least appealing in their fantasy lives
if you think about romance novels and
bodice Ripper romances I mean they're
all about the guy not being able to
control himself and and like I will die
if I don't have you kind of thing
um and the idea that somebody could be
that incredibly devoted to you I think
is appealing to women who are often very
interested in commitment right and the
idea that you would have that kind of
power over another individual in that
sense I think is appealing so I think
that that could be part of it
um there's also
um you know been this sort of idea
tossed around that it could be similar
to
um
what we see in some other animal species
where females will
um require males to demonstrate their
own sort of physical prowess and so my
favorite example when talking about with
students is what we call the bump test
and so this is something that happens in
Gladiator frogs and so Gladiator fries
will approach a female frog and she will
actually be aggressive towards him and
if he runs away she won't mate with him
but if he's pushy back then she'll
actually have sex with him right so
she's like selecting for sort of
aggressive and physical strength on the
part of the male frog right and so
there's this idea that maybe females are
doing that you know unconsciously in
humans sometimes and they may be
initiating this because they actually
are you know taking some sort of reward
or pleasure in testing male ability to
demonstrate their strength right in the
same way that women might enjoy watching
men compete in different kinds of
physical Sports
um because again it's sort of showing
off prowess
that makes sense it's the closest I
suppose that a woman could get to
experiencing a man's physical strength
kind of all uh brought to bear on her
yeah yeah I think it's like if you
imagine the sort of the kinds of some of
the kinds of things that are that that
are in that assessment of rough sex
right it would include things like
wrestling right and sort of that kind of
play fighting and overpowering kind of
thing and yeah it is it's typically
going to be the closest thing that you
would experience to that and so it is a
way of sort of trying to assess that and
in a playful way not really a
threatening way
what about the novelty seeking but not
aggression thing
yeah well so that was mostly looking at
sort of motivations and the idea that
just sort of trying new things openness
to experience is associated with it so
in the study there were a bunch of
different questions that asked them
about what kinds of things and
experiences do you find associated with
your experiences of rough sex whether
it's a male or a female initiating it
and one of the things that popped out
was this idea about trying it because
it's something different it's something
new we were bored
um you know we saw in in a movie you
know different things like that being
indicators and it was correlated with a
bunch of other things that are
associated with novelty seeking like
having sex in public places
um engaging in
um sex with sex toys things like that so
it seemed to be more about novelty than
about aggression in terms of like
having negative feelings about the
person that you're being aggressive
towards
um and the one sort of one that that was
also in there that that
um that we talked about that is it's
interesting because it kind of has a
little bit of overlap is this issue
about sexual jealousy that when men may
be experiencing sexual jealousy they may
be more likely to engage in rough sex
and in particular the rough sex was
actually just being rougher during the
sex act thrusting harder
um penetrating further what was
interesting about that is that the women
reported experiencing a shorter duration
to orgasm
when they engaged in that kind of sex so
I mean it could be rewarding for the
women because it's actually maybe extra
arousing maybe providing better
stimulation how did you study the that
we asked people we didn't right like
have them come into the lab and tell
them we want you to have sex like you
really you've got it you've got another
half an inch out of it though you've
done very well
yeah we did not do that although it
would be fabulous if somebody did do
that kind of study but no we did not we
were asking undergraduates so we did not
have them come in
engage in activities glad that you
didn't have to go through that what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]